like a second start
yeah so today i'm going to tell you
about two concepts
algorithmic stability and differential
privacy i don't need to tell you about
differential privacy for the last one
and half does i have heard enough of it
but the term algorithmic stability may
not be obvious
up front i'll make it precise as i move
ahead in the talk
but to keep a high level picture in mind
you can think that it is a property of
an algorithm
which ensures that if i change the input
to the algorithm slightly
then the output of the algorithm does
not change dramatically what i mean by
slight change to the input
and dramatic change to the output i will
make it precise
good so the main thesis of today's talk
is going to be
if you have a algorithm or a function
which is stable under some notions of
stability
then you can translate it into a
differentially private algorithm
via generic transformations and the main
focus of today's talk will be to design
such generic transformations
so what's the talk outline in the first
part of the talk
i will tell you how to design
differentially private algorithms
just by using stability property of a
given function so i want to get a
differentially private variant of a
particular function
and i will use the stability property of
that function to get the differentially
private variant
and this in some sense would be a meta
algorithm or a template algorithm
in the second part of the talk i'll tell
you about the sample and aggregate
framework which was introduced in
katrina stock
and i will use it for the problem of
model selection
while preserving differential privacy in
the design of that algorithm
what i will do is i will use the tools
that i design in the first part
this meta algorithm to design the sample
and aggregate framework for this
specific problem
now in the third part of the talk i will
take a significant detour from
differential privacy literature
and go into high dimensional statistics
so i will
revisit a problem called sparse linear
regression which is like really well
studied in high dimensional statistics
and kind of review some of the
theoretical properties that are known
in the fourth part of the talk what i'll
do is i'll again get back to
differential privacy
and now the tools which i have defined
in the first two parts
i'll use that to get a differentially
private algorithms for sparse linear
regression
and the key feature of our private
algorithm is that
we'll have sample complexity almost
nearly as optimal as compared to the
non-private ones
so by sample complexity you can think
the number of data samples you need
to get consistent answer roughly that's
what it means by sample complexity
so let's start with the first part now
to tell you about the
first part i have to define some notion
of stability so that grim
gives us our first specific notion of
stability
called perturbation stability now for
people who are conversant with the
differential privacy literature
this is essentially zero local
sensitivity but if you don't know don't
bother
so what is perturbation stability you
have a function f and you have a data
set d
now this function takes this data set
and produces some output let's say
mickey mouse
now if i change one entry in the data
set the output the function does not
change
so perturbation stability yeah
perturbation stability of a function at
a data set d
is that the output of the function does
not change on changing any one entry of
the data set d
and this is equivalently saying that the
local sensitivity of the function
at d is zero
one thing to keep in mind is this
property is of a function at a data set
otherwise the property becomes trivial
so this is one thing to keep in mind
now to design a differentially private
algorithm using stability property we
have to extend this
like change of one data entry to let's
say change of k data entries
so we say a function is k stable at a
data set d
what i mean by that is that if i change
any k entries on the data set
the output of the function does not
change so i need to change at least k
entries in the data set to change the
output of the function
now we define another term called
distance to instability which says that
which essentially says that the minimum
number of entries in the function
and data set i need to change to change
the output of the function
or in other words the maximum k for
which f of d is case stable
so pictorially thinking you have this
space of all data sets
these are the red regions of the data
sets which are not perturbation stable
meaning that changing one entry
changes the output of the function and
the
this blue islands are the data sets
which are stable
perturbation stable and this data set d
which is k stable
lies like at least k hops from the
boundary so that's a perturbation stable
let us say a case stable let us say
now our objective which is not
surprising that we want to output f of t
while preserving differential privacy so
this is a very generic problem we want
to solve
and i will give you a framework how to
do this just by using the property of
the function f
so to do that i'll introduce this
framework called the proposed test and
release framework
so this framework has appeared in a
variety of forms in the earlier
literature
starting with working lay in 2009 then
karwa raskolnikova smith
step in 2011 and recently in a paper of
adam and mine and the version which i'll
be telling you today is from our paper
so what is it the algorithm is extremely
simple so our objective is to output f
of d
while preserving differential privacy
the algorithm is as follows
compute the distance to instability of
the function at d
you are given the data set you want to
compute the distance to instability
meaning that the minimum number of
entries in the data set d
i need to change to change output of the
function
let's call that dist at laplace noise
one by epsilon to it now
yesterday i think katrina told about the
laplace noise it's a double exponential
distribution
with standard deviation root 2 upon
epsilon it's a symmetric noise yeah
you have this noise and then you check
if this the noisy distance
is greater than log 1 by delta upon
epsilon so
epsilon and delta the privacy parameters
so you're dealing with epsilon delta
differential privacy
if it is greater than log 1 by delta
upon epsilon then just return f of d
exactly otherwise fail with
showing something bought now one thing
is that
if the algorithm succeeds it gives the
answer exactly
so this is to stress on the point which
uh katrina was telling yesterday that
not always you have to give a noisy
answer so in this case the algorithm
will output exact answer
if it succeeds
two important points i want to mention
here that
first thing is that notice that this is
just laplace mechanism what i'm using
why am i saying it's a laplace mechanism
if you think carefully the function dist
is actually a function with global
sensitivity 1.
but by adding laplace noise of 1 by
epsilon i am essentially making this
till the differentially private
this is one property which i want to
keep in mind we'll use this while
analyzing the properties of the
algorithm
the second thing is that given as it is
it is not obvious if the algorithm
is computationally efficient because the
first step is not clear how to compute
efficiently
these are the two things i want to keep
in mind
in terms of the properties of the
algorithm the algorithm is epsilon delta
differentially private
and the second property is the utility
guarantee
it says that if the function is 2 log 1
by delta upon epsilon stable
at d that means i need to change at
least 2 log 1 by delta 1 epsilon points
in
data set d to change the output of the
function then with probability 1 minus
delta the algorithm will output f of t
so this seems like a pretty nice
property of the algorithm accepting we
don't know how to compute this test
let's keep that aside now the next few
slides what i will do is
i'll give you almost the complete proof
of both the theorems these are like
pretty simple to prove so i'll give you
both
complete proof of both of them so let's
start with the privacy guarantee
so the claim is that the algorithm is
epsilon delta differentially private
as with analyzing any epsilon any
differentially private algorithm
will consider two datasets d and d prime
which are neighbors
that means that they differ in exactly
one entry
now to show the property of differential
privacy
we need to show that all for all
possible sets of answers is
the algorithm on d and d prime in
s are the probability measures are close
and they are close by this
multiplicative of it is zero of epsilon
and additive of delta
so this is pretty standard accepting
in this case we will be analyzing the to
show this property we'll analyze it
in two different cases first case when f
of d
the output of the function on d and d
prime are exactly the same
so this is case one and case two is when
f of d is not equal to f of d prime
so we will analyze it in these two cases
let's look at case one when f of d is
equal to f of d prime
notice that it suffices to show that the
algorithm which i call as a ptr
because it's proposed test and release i
need to show these two properties
the probability of outputting a bot in
both the cases
are multiplicative close and since i've
already assumed f of d is called f of d
prime i need to show that
running on data set d and data set d
prime the probability of outputting f of
d in both the cases
are again multiplicatively close because
the algorithm can only output either of
these two things
either about or the f of b
now i told you that computation of this
disk tilde the
noisy distance to instability is epsilon
differentially private
so that essentially ensures that
we get these two properties almost for
free the moment we see
distilled is epsilon differentially
private think of it what i am doing
i am computing this tilde then i am
thresholding
and then i am choosing one from the
possible outputs that is either f of d
or bot and in this case the output space
for both
d and d prime are exactly the same so
it's just nothing but post processing
after computing this tilde and we know
that when you do post processing on
differentially private algorithm it
still remains differentially private
so this essentially proves the first
part
now let's look at the case when f of d
is not equal to f of d prime
in this case since f of this is not
equal to f of d prime by definition
the distance to instability for on d
and on data set d prime is exactly equal
to zero because changing one entry
changes the output
now from this we can conclude that
with probability at least one minus
delta
the probability that ptr outputs
d or d on either d or d prime
is bought i mean the with probabilities
is one minus delta p t
r on d or d prime will output a bot
now this might not be that obvious so
let's look at why it is true
so both of them have distance to
instability 0 so both are at 0.
now i'm adding laplace noise of order 1
by epsilon so this means
by the tail probability of laplace
distribution
with at least 1 minus delta probability
this tilde will always be below this
threshold of log 1 by delta 1 epsilon in
both the cases
and when it is below this threshold i
always output a bot
so this property is true now i need
additional one additional property to
guarantee that differential privacy
holds
is that since distance is zero
distance to instability in both axis is
zero ptr of d
for outputting a bot and ptr of d prime
outputting about are exactly equal
because i start with the same distance
to instability for both the cases
and this essentially concludes the flow
questions
the utility analysis is actually much
simpler than this it's
on pretty much straightforward so now it
might
so in literally what i wanted to show
that if the algorithm or the function
is 2 log 1 by delta upon epsilon stable
then with one minus delta probability i
output f of d exactly that was my claim
now when it is 2 log 1 by delta 1
epsilon stable that means this
is at least step 2 log 1 by delta 1
epsilon
now when i add laplace noise to it again
by the tail property of laplace
distribution
no oh yeah
this tilde cannot be below log 1 by
delta 1 epsilon
so with 1 minus delta probability i will
output f of b exactly
so this concludes the proof of the
utility guarantee
so now what i have told you using this
function
f's perturbation stability property i
have given you a differentially private
version of f of t it's a pretty generic
transformation for the function f
accepting i haven't told you how to run
this algorithm computationally
efficiently
and yeah so
this brings us to the second part of the
talk but i will show you an application
of this framework
with in conjunction with sample and
aggregate and i will show that how to
design this computational efficient
versions of
distance to instability and we will look
at private model selection
so sample and aggregate framework
is one of the most well-studied things
in differential privacy literature i
think
it was initially proposed proposed by
nissim rashford nikov and smith in 2007.
then followed up by smith in 2011 and in
a recent version of our paper we have
looked at it again
and the version which i'm going to tell
you today is from our paper
just to review sample and aggregate
framework you have a data set d
you take sub samples from this data set
d i will tell you how you take sub
samples but
we take small sub samples of data city
d1
till dm and you run your favorite
algorithm
on each of these data blocks it doesn't
really matter what you run
then you feed the outputs of this
algorithm to this magic box
called the aggregator and aggregator
does something on it
and produces an output so this is a high
level picture of sample and aggregate
framework
what we know about these properties we
know that
under this assumption that each entry in
this original data set
appears in at most say eta number of
blocks
so i constrain that each entry can
appear in either number of blocks
then under that assumption if the
aggregator is epsilon by eta
differentially private
then the overall framework is epsilon
differentially private
sorry this should be eta here it's not
one
so what is the proof the proof is pretty
straightforward
i can treat as each block as a data
sample now and one entry can appear in
either number of blocks
and since the aggregator is epsilon by
data differentially private pretty much
i get the
privacy guarantee directly
so i have told you about the privacy
guarantee of sample and aggregate
framework
accepting i haven't
told you how to really create this
aggregator i said like if the aggregator
is epsilon
epsilon by eta comma delta
differentially private then i get this
property
now let's look at how you construct this
aggregator
let's assume that the
algorithm which you are running this
your favorite algorithm it produces
something in the discrete range space
let's say there are possible outputs s1
till sr
now the algorithm runs on each of these
blocks
now what i will do is the aggregator
will be as follows each of the blocks
vote for one of the outputs which is it
has picked
and there will be histogram and this
histogram of council looks something
like this
yeah so for this part just pretend that
one entry appears in one block it's
easier to
understand here so now
i will use the this ptr framework for
generating the indicator so my function
f in the ptr framework will be the
candidate
output to the maximum number of votes so
that's my
so i take the histogram i take the
bucket which has the maximum number of
votes and that is my f
i can fit into the ptr framework
do you one question now is that what
this disk would look like
in this case any ideas
so title
ah this the cost of max of this
okay we can do slightly better than that
what you can look at is the distance gap
between the highest and the second
highest
and changing one data sample essentially
will decrease the count of one of the
bin by one and increase the other by one
adam you'll be confused
distance over two the distance reduces
by two so
the gap reduces maybe the number of
steps i need to
shrink that right oh no sorry sorry i
just
so yeah this is the first observation
that i don't need to really look at the
max i can just look at the gap
that is actually helpful for us
and this second observation the way i
have stated the problem i mean the
algorithm
it now becomes obvious that this is
computationally efficient
not always will be in this regime that
will have computational efficient
versions of this disk but in this case
it is and actually most of the work
in during this talk will be designing
this function test
so yeah so we have a kind of
computational efficient
version of the aggregator with sample
and aggregate framework we have
differential privacy
from now on i'll continue calling this
form the aggregator sptr plus report
noisy max aggregator
so in some sense i'm taking the max pin
and
report i mean reporting the noisy
version of it and i am using the pdf
framework so i'll call it ptf plus
report noisy max
now i have told you about the privacy
property of the sample and aggregate
framework
but i haven't told anything about the
utility guarantee of this algorithm
so to state the utility guarantee of
this algorithm we have to work under a
notion of stability what you call as a
sub sampling stability
so first i've told you about
perturbation stability now to analyze
the utility of the sample and aggregate
framework
will work under the sub sampling
stability so what is sub sampling
stability
if it changes slides yes
again you have the teracent d now
think that the way i'm generating d i
each of the data blocks is that
i look at each of these data each of the
entries in this original data set and
with probability p
i pick the data sample or probability q
i pick the data sample
and that forms my data blocks
obviously the way i have constructed the
data sets each entry will appear in
multiple number of blocks because i am
sampling with replacement
will handle with that later but the
stability property
is that if i take any of the data blocks
the function on the data set
agrees with the function in the original
data set with probability significantly
more than half let us say three-fourth
that's the stability property i need
from the function on this data set
so this is what i mean by sub sampling
stable at data safety
good
so we'll choose the probability which
here pick a sample
to be q which is epsilon by log 1 by
delta not necessary i mean this
pretty much follows from the
calculations but you don't need to
remember this
another thing is that in expectation
each entry of d
will appear in like around mq number of
blocks
and we'll show that with high
probability it will appear in atmosphere
mq number of blocks
now in one interesting property is that
on the sub sampling stability
the histogram of counts would look
something like this
the highest guy would get around like
three-fourths of all the ports
that means the second highest gate
cannot get more than one-fourth of the
volts
so the gap will be around half
yeah so now i feed our sample and
aggregate framework
this ptr plus report noisy max to make
sure what we get from here
so in d i i sample each entry with this
probability q
just by turn of bound each entry of d
appears in
at most 2 mq number of blocks
now my distance is the
number of votes for the highest win
minus the number of votes for the second
has been
by two and since one entry appears in
two mq blocks
i scale it by another factor of two mq
and minus 1 basically
to make sure that i mean i have to be
one step away
and then i add laplace noise to it check
the distance higher than
log 1 by delta 1 epsilon i written f of
t otherwise return a bot
so just to understand so when you say
that this last uh slide when you said
that this stability you know
with the probability at least three
quarters that's the probability over the
data distribution
the probability of the sampling over the
sampling over this
what is the subsampling probabilities
for any sub sample
for any subsample so i pick a sub sample
for that sum sample
the probability that the function on
that sum sample agrees with the
function of the units it does not depend
on the probability of electric for
the size of the sensor no
no um the question right sorry so so
does it depend on the
the fraction what is the size of this
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's already stated
in terms of a given sampling rate
something okay
so this algorithm is epsilon comma 2
delta differentially private
so original algorithm was epsilon comma
definition delta differentially private
but since i have this failure
probability that it appears in 2mq
blocks
we get another delta factor here
i hadn't told you how many number of
blocks you need to take for the utility
if you take m the number of blocks to be
like log n upon
whatever upon 1 by q squared then with 1
minus 2 delta probability the true
answer is f of t
this is essentially channel point
nothing fancy going on here
so these are the two properties of this
algorithm one there
now
one thing to notice here is that the
utility guarantee the way i have stated
it
does not depend on the number of
candidate outputs
i just need the number of outputs to be
discrete
so what do you mean by modules models
essentially yeah so what do i mean by
models
models are the basically you can think
that s one to less ski are the discrete
set of models which are from which i
checked
so yeah this doesn't depend on the
number of samples and for people who are
converts into the exponential mechanism
and things like that
if we use exponential mechanism for the
same problem you will incur
log dependence on the number of models
which you don't have a dependency here
but so
this
ends the second part of the talk so i
have told you about
two types of algorithms one this
stability based meta algorithm
then i have told you about oh sure fine
um just
one more comments last question about
this
as you mentioned this really works when
i have discrete
set of candidate solutions um
but like it seems like it shouldn't be
any problem to switch to
instead of discrete to something which
is continuous but
it's not that simple right it's not
because the problem has happened
when you are around the boundary so i
can discretize and yeah i can just open
up where
what is my division is right here in
practice it might work
maybe it's a question for john are they
like um harness results or some sort of
improvement there
if something differential you know
hardness results
it's just absolutely
so for learning there are some and so
these are in
some of our papers
sorry about it so now i'll move away
from differential privacy for the next
15-20 minutes
i'll go into high-dimensional statistics
and sparse linear regression
so i'll study the problem of sparse
linear regression for some time
in the high dimensions and i'll be
telling you about this estimator which
is like really famous called the lasso
estimator
and study some of its like properties
which are known till now
so what is this first linear regression
problem
you have a data set of n samples
each sample in the data set is a tuple
of two one
a feature vector of dimension p and the
response
y now the
modeling assumption is that y is
generated via noisy linear transform
on x so you have a hidden parameter
vector theta star
which is of dimension p you multiply the
feature vector
add some field noise to it and generate
y
so this is how x and y y is generated
from x
for simplicity throughout that i'll
assume that x is l infinity bounded by
one
this is one thing to keep in mind and
let's say the field noise is sub
gaussian so
by sub gaussian i mean that is always
upper bounded by washington
now i can think of this complete data
set as a stacked up matrix
where each row of the data set is one of
the feature vector
and you know in completeness i will call
it as design matrix
and y is similarly the response vector
theta star remains the parameter vector
and w is a field noise vector now
now the high level goal is to
find out given y and x i have to find
theta star
and the regime i will be working in is
in the high dimensional region where the
dimensions
can be significantly higher than the
number of data samples i have
now as you might think that this problem
does not make sense
though i have stated it it's an
extremely underdefined problem
you have any you have p variables in
equations
you cannot get anything meaningful
although if we make some assumptions on
the system
we might be able to get something so
what's the assumption
we'll assume that theta star has at most
s non-zero entries
and let's say it is smaller than n
additionally this is some kind of a
technical requirement for the
algorithm specific algorithm which i am
telling to work but the assumption is
that
each entry of theta star is bounded
away from zero by phi and bounded away
from one by one minus five
and phi is like arbitrarily small
constant doesn't matter
now the model selection problem which
i'll be looking at is find the non-zero
coordinates of theta star
so i want to find where this green
region is right
that's all my problem is surprisingly
this problem is actually tractable
and this has been studied from like
long back and i'm not sure i'm citing
the earliest paper but
the closest i could go was 1994. so
typically in 1994 then after
it all in 2003 and then there was a
whole series of work after that
so this is this estimator is called the
lasso estimator
so what is the lasso estimator you take
the least squared loss
add the regularizer l1 norm of the
model theta multiplied by lambda which
is a regularization coefficient
and for people who do not remember the
l1 norm it is just the sum of the
absolute values which i have written
there
so this is the regularization
and but the properties of the last
estimator says that
if i make suitable assumptions on the
design matrix and the response
and the fill noise then
the theta hat which i will be getting
the nonzero coordinates of theta hat
will essentially equal
the coordinates of the underlying
parameter vector
so in some sense i will recover the
model using the lasso estimator
this is the thing so let us get into
some more specific details about it
so the conditions under which lasso will
give you meaningful results
are called the consistency conditions
there are variety of consistency
conditions which have been studied in
the literature
i will be focusing on two of them
one is i mean both these papers kind of
cite the similar consistency conditions
one is by one right in 2006
and the second one is by zhao and you in
2007
and also i will not tell you all the
consistency conditions which are
basically
most which i think are most important
those are the conditions i will be
telling you that's why there is a star
there
so let's look at the design matrix x so
this was
this block and let's
let gamma be the nonzero coordinates of
theta star
so we split the design matrix into two
part x comma
the columns which are non zero and x
gamma complement
the first condition tells that in
coherence basically increase at a high
level say that
the columns of this guy should not kind
of interfere with the columns of this k
otherwise i just cannot find out the
coordinates
formally it says that if i look the
covariance matrix inverse covariance
of x gamma
and then i correlate it with x gamma
complement
transpose x gamma then that quantity in
l infi
so this is the matrix infinity now l
infinity to l infinity now is bounded by
one force
you don't need to remember the exact
form of the statement but essentially
this says that
these two guys do not interact too much
with each other
the second property is what is called
the restricted strong convexity
so this says that if i look at the
covariance matrix
just on x comma the minimum eigen value
of this guy
is at least n sorry it's not the
normalized
features no it's not covariance matrix
so
yeah that's right so this is the form we
should keep in mind 1 by 2 n
so everything nothing normally and this
kind of makes sense because
i told you that each coordinate of x
each feature vectors each coordinate is
l infinity bounded by one so i am
thinking that the norm of the vector is
like around root p
so newton
so theorem under the star property that
other some additional
assumptions if i choose my lambda
property
and allow my number of samples to grow
as
s log p s was the sparsity and log p is
the number of dimensions
then the support of the lasso estimator
theta hat
equals the support of theta star and
this is
again from these two papers
and the assumptions are in coherence and
restrict a strong convexity
so this is the consistency property of
the lasso estimator
what our job today will be to find out a
differentially private version of the
loss of estimator
using in some sense is consistency
conditions and that is what is going to
be the rest of the talk
so the consistency conditions are like
the deterministic conditions
if you think that yeah if the
entries in the design matrix are drawn
from normal 0 1 or 1 fourth
then the assumptions above are satisfied
with high probability
so this is again from these two papers
and it's not really hard to show that
good so we have two sets of consistency
conditions
one the deterministic ones and there is
a specific
stochastic model which satisfies the
consistency conditions so these are the
two things to keep in mind
now that brings us what we show in our
paper so this is the paper with adam
first we show consistency conditions
if the consistency conditions sold then
that would imply perturbation stability
of the loss of estimator what it means
that
the nonzero coordinates of the support
of theta hat
won't change if i change a few entries
in a data sample
so the property number one but that is
not good enough for me to get
differential privacy
i have to test this property in some
sense
so what we show that
testing for perturbation stability
directly is not easy to do
instead what you do is we design certain
proxy conditions
which would imply perturbation stability
and what you show is that this proxy
conditions are efficiently testable
number one and efficiently meaning
computationally efficiently
and number two you can test that with
differential privacy
this is still not over because if this
how good are these proxy conditions so i
have to finally compare the consistency
conditions
the third leg is the consistency com
conditions
imply the proxy conditions
now it is kind of clear so we are not
making any additional assumptions on the
system
we work with the assumptions which are
known from the consistency
there we show that consistency implies
proxy conditions and this proxy
conditions inside
perturbation stability
so that brings us to the fourth part of
the talk
so we list the two consistency
conditions
one is the one is the infinity norm
another one is the smallest eigenvalues
say efficiently testable that means you
don't want to test the disk
no we don't think the test comes
consistency conditions we test some
version called the proxy conditions
proxy conditions and consistency
conditions would imply those proxy
conditions
so that means the proxy conditions is
weaker and it doesn't guarantee the
lasso system to
work right no i mean consistency
conditions imply those conditions
yeah so it's it's weak reputation
consistency condition implies proxies
proxy is a
weaker than consistency so we show that
if proxy conditions hold then
stability holds proxy conditions
alone may not guarantee consistency of
lasso
right but consistency implies the lasso
and what you are saying that we just
need something weaker to test for
stability
okay but you can test these conditions
yeah we cannot test consistency
conditions for privacy we just need to
test the proxy conditions
so his question i think if i understood
the question correctly the question is
that
proxy conditions are weaker conditions
with consistency
and just allowing the proxy conditions
to be true
does not necessarily mean that lasso is
consistent
so the point is that consistency
conditions will imply the proxy
conditions
which would essentially mean that lasso
estimator actually gives you meaningful
results and that has two consistency
conditions have to be true
we need this proxy conditions to make
sure that it is differentially private
so at a high level what you are saying
the
conditions which i need to make lasso
stable
or differentially private are weaker
than the
conditions which are necessary for lasso
to give you consistent results
adam do you want to add something to
that
so the consistency conditions are is it
known that they are necessary
some versions of them are known to be
necessary but not exactly the same
conditions
i'm sorry if you said that is are the
consistency conditions
testable efficiently without privacy no
it's not clear it can be decided i mean
i mean the way i've stated it's the
deterministic conditions consistently
conditions
actually sorry you you cannot test them
privately without even with the privacy
because you just don't know the support
of theta star
you don't know theta star so don't know
the support of theta star and
consistency conditions are on theta star
underlying model so that you cannot do
good
so more questions
so that brings us to the fourth part of
the talk so now i will be using the
tools which i have defined in the first
two parts
one is this ptr framework second is the
sample and aggregate framework and this
report noisy max plus ptr aggregator
to design a differentially private
algorithm for sparse integration
in fact i'll tell you about not an
algorithm couple of algorithms
the first one will be extremely simple
so you'll use a simple sub sampling
based private losses algorithm
so you just use the sub sampling
property to design a private loss
algorithm
and this will actually have very good
sample complexity as of as it is
so let's start it so
till now i haven't told like what is the
privacy model for the problem
so the model which you are looking at is
like one row in the data set corresponds
to one feature vector and one response
so and a neighboring data set
is where i have changed one of the
feature vector and one of the responses
so this is what i mean by neighboring
just recap of sub sampling stability of
the data you run
random sub sample with replacement
stability implies that with probability
three fourth f of d i equals f of d
now in the report noisy max aggregator
my set of candidate models will be all
the p chooses models so i have
p coordinates out of which i know s of
them which i am looking for a particular
s
of them so my all candidates are p
chooses
i run my function f on it which is the
loss of estimator in this case
take the vote
now i use the same sampling probability
each entry appears into
mq blocks m is n log n by delta upon q
squared
i run exactly the ptr plus report noisy
my segregator
now for the sub sampling stability of
lasso
we will work with the stochastic
assumption for simplicity so each entry
in x
is drawn from 0 1 the noise is iodine
gaussian
this is my response vector design matrix
in the same system as it is
so the result from wind right and so
says that
under proper choice of lambda and if you
select n to grow as like s log p
support of the lasso estimator theta hat
equals the support of theta star so this
is what they had shown
what we show is the following
if you choose lambda properly again and
if you allow your samples number of
samples to grow
at least as s log p times log 1 by delta
1 epsilon
so i just blow up the sample complexity
by this factor of log 1 by delta 1
epsilon
and of course i choose my function to be
lasso
then the output of the aggregator equals
the support of theta star
so this very simple algorithm why i did
not even need to
know any specific properties of the
lasso estimator already gives me a
sample complexity we just
blown up by this factor of log one by
delta one epsilon
so this was kind of i mean we found it
to be really cool when we can
encounter it questions here
so yeah couple of things notice that
this is log 1 by delta 1 epsilon blow up
this is in some sense annoying in cases
where
the scale of delta is let's say 1 by n
to the power omega of 1
in this case it's kind of annoying this
log n term will be showing up everywhere
i don't want that
so the approach we know to kind of
remove this property
this this kind of extra blow up now we
have to go into like specific geometry
of the last estimator
and that is going to be the next part of
the talk
now we are going to tell you about
perturbation stability based lasso
which will have optimal sample
complexity in some sense it will have s
log p no log 1 by delta 1 epsilon term
extra
so to design this perturbation stability
framework
we have to kind of understand the
geometry of lasso now
before i do that i'll just recap the
distance to instability framework in the
first
part that a function is case stable if i
change k entries in the data set the
output of the function doesn't change
distance to instability the minimum
number of samples i need to change
to change the output of f of t and my
objective was to output f of t while
plus having privacy
this is again the recap of the ptr
framework you compute this you compute
this tilde
and and then threshold it and if
it is higher than the threshold then you
output f of t otherwise you output a
bond
now to design our perturbation stability
based framework our main
kind of all the creativity will go on in
designing this
test so essentially we'll fill it in
some
global sensitivity one function it is
not clear what is going to be
apparently
and majority of the rest of the talk
will be
actually kind of designing this function
global sensitivity and function
so so this is the lasso estimator
which you had least squared loss plus l1
regularization
and my function f is the support of
theta hat
the issue is like pretty evident that
for this function f given function f is
not clear how to compute the distance
between stability
and under what conditions this is
satisfied that is also not clear
so we have to address this issue
again our this three arrow figure
we have consistency conditions imply
perturbation stability
we will use proxy conditions to get
perturbation stability and consistency
conditions would imply perturbation
stability
i will not speak about all these three
arrows i will speak about only two of
them today
one consistency conditions imply
perturbation stability number one
number two the proxy conditions
imply perturbation stability so these
are the two things we'll be looking at
so let's start with the first arrow
consistency conditions imply
perturbation stability the theorem we
want to prove is that
under the consistency conditions of
lasso
the support of the minimizer theta hat
is perturbation stable
so a proof sketch of this will look at
the kkt optimality condition of the
minimizer
of the objective function and in the
next stage will show that
the support of theta hat is stable by
using what is called as a dual
certificate
or nearby stable instances so i will
construct in some sense
the minimizer for the perturbed instance
so that is what i call as a dual
certificate
and this style of proof has been also
used by when wright in
his paper to show consistency so this
proof argument is not me
so to do that let's call the objective
function as g of theta
the gradient of the last estimator is
essentially this x transpose y minus x
theta take a negative sign
plus lambda times the sub derivative of
the l1 regularization
now the minimizer will lie somewhere
here and in most cases it will be a
non-differentiable point
so 0 lies in the subgradient of the
minimizer now if i change one data
sample
the objective function changes here by
changing the data sample
and i have to argue that this theta hat
what i am getting
theta hat prime actually shares the same
support as theta hat
so to do that we have to ensure two
properties
which i will use the optimality
conditions to show
that no zero coordinates of theta hat
becomes non zero and theta hat prime
and do that we'll use the mutual
inquiries
condition
the second part that no non-zero
coordinates of theta hat
becomes zero and theta hat prime for
that we will use the restricted strong
convexity
so this is the proof sketch and for this
part actually i will not go into more
detail of it but
as i move forward i will tell you about
the step how this conditions kind of
imply stability perturbation stability
and there it will be clear that why you
actually need to test for these
conditions
so that brings us to testing the
perturbation stability of the loss of
estimator
so again the problem is i have given
this last estimate of theta hat
i want to see if i change one or few
samples in
the data set does the support of theta
hat change
so let's split up theta hat into two
parts
gamma is the support of theta hat gamma
complement is the sub rotors
which are in the non zero coordinates of
theta now why do i do this
if you remember the consistency
conditions those who are defined over
gamma
which was the support of theta star but
certainly i don't have access to theta
star
only thing i have access to is theta hat
might as well work with it
so gamma is a support of theta hat and
we'll use this proxy for now
to test for stability we need to test
for two properties
restricted strong convexity minimum
eigenvalue is at least 10
and now instead of testing for the
incoherence condition will test for
something called a strong stability
which is also implied by this
consistency condition which essentially
says that
there is no negative here so the
absolute
the typo there is no negative the
absolute value of the coordinates of the
gradient
on the support gamma complement so if i
look at the
gradient of the least squared loss on
the support of gamma complement
that is much smaller than lambda
so in some sense this i mean i'll go
into the details of it in a couple of
slides but what
at a high level this statement is saying
is that
if to begin with at theta hat the list
got losses gradient is much smaller than
lambda
then even by changing a few samples it
cannot go beyond lambda
so 0 has to be in the sub gradient of
that center so that's the high level
property should be bounded
this is where it's necessary so because
if it is bounded away from zero
yeah if it is too close to zero you know
so the restrictions from convexity
basically means that
my theta hat primes in the non-zero
coordinates will be
like theta hat prime and theta hat will
be close now if theta hat is bounded
away from zero then theta prime will
also be bounded away from zero
that's why you need the boundedness
condition and
bounded away from one is a technical
condition basically it says that you
don't go into some kind of like
region at the boundary of some set
that's the point
so let's look at the geometry of the
lasso now
so you will use strong convexity to
ensure that support of theta hat
is within the support of theta prime
so basically i want to make sure that
any nonzero coordinate of theta
does not become zero and theta prime
strong convexity will ensure that theta
had gamma minus theta prime gamma is the
support
and then theta had come this are bounded
in the l infinity now
actually this will show that these are
bound in the electron
and this is like standard like analysis
for
any kind of elm kind of analysis
so this is one thing first it will show
now secondly if theta hat on gamma
is sufficiently large then this will
ensure that this guy is also
greater than zero because this is small
consistency conditions will imply that
theta hats values on those coordinates
actually greater than zero because i
started that theta star has a
is bounded away from zero so theta hat
is also bounded away from zero that is
consistency condition also
so by showing these three properties
will essentially make sure that the
support of theta hat
is within the support of theta hat prime
now to look at pictorially what is
happening
theta hat is line so i am taking the
objective function and taking one slice
of the objective function
since i can draw two i mean i'm not good
at drawing 3d figures
so you look at in the direction where
theta hat is non-zero so gamma is in the
support of theta hat now the objective
function will look something like this
because there is strong convexity so
more precisely it will be bounded by a
quadratic from below
so if i change some samples in the data
set
the minimizer in this direction cannot
move really too far
because a strong convexity will push me
back
and as a result the first property we
made sure is true
so this is the first part that i do not
lose non-zero coordinates when i move to
theta prime
now the second part is actually going to
be a bit more involved
now i have to argue that no zero
coordinates of theta hat
becomes non-zero and theta star
now now strong convexity cannot come to
my rescue because in those coordinates i
just don't have strong convexity
i just have on the support
curiously since we have added the l1
regularization
if i look at now gamma complement this
theta hat lies in the minimizer here
that means the objective function has a
slope of at least minus lambda plus
lambda in this directions
so to move theta hat become non-zero it
has to be this slope
so whatever gradient i add it has to go
beyond this slope
in any of these coordinates so for the
minimizer to move along gamma complement
the perturbation to the least squared
loss has to be something that
it pushes me out of lambda so if i
ensure that each
element of the gradient of the least
squared loss is much smaller than lambda
then changing one entry cannot push me
above above lambda
and that will ensure that my minimizer
in that direction cannot become non-zero
notice that i have not tested about for
mutual incorrect kind of conditions it
was hard to test
so we just boiled it down to this
property
so formally what i am saying
if the gradient of the least squared
loss which is essentially this guy
theta which i don't care about right now
gamma complement is like ai till ap
if each of the coordinates are much
smaller than lambda
then i complement has to have a sub
gradient of 0 and that as a d
prime because by changing one entry we
can show that
this thing doesn't change by that much
under the consistency conditions
that is important so if consistency
conditions doesn't hold these things do
not hold
so under consistency conservation this
thing is true
so at least one thing i have convinced
you that
these are computational efficient tests
by which you can make sure that lasso is
stable
this is a sufficient condition
what i haven't told you is how to get
these conditions while preserving
differential privacy
immediately when you try to make this
test of these two conditions
differentially private you run into
trouble
and oh no yeah so i have to test for
restricted strong convexity
which in itself like if i know the
support gamma
then testing it is like pretty easy
because it's just the eigenvalues
and changing one entry in the data set
changes the
covariance matrix by a rank on
perturbation wells inequality will tell
that it just changes by small amount
the problem is i don't know gamma
without frame i mean when i'm
using the data privately using
differential privacy i just cannot have
direct access to gamma
so what do i do i don't even know the
set
to add on to my travels when i'm testing
this
strong stability the strong stability
property of the test
at the minimizer theta hat on those
coordinates which are 0 again i don't
know gamma complement
the issue is that if
g1 is greater than certain threshold t1
the minimum eigenvalue and g2 is greater
than certain threshold t2
then we can show that these two
functions have low sensitivity
if either of them are below the
threshold we don't know anything about
them
now just just to start with this
condition
it's not clear how to get differential
privacy so essentially pictorially can
think that if g2 is this side and v1 is
this side
if both of them are in this region i
know they are stable or
low sensitive but if either of them is
outside the
region then i don't know how to test it
kind of a puzzle question from this
condition how can i get a differential
how can i get a function of global
sensitivity one which is meaningful
i'll just make a global sensitivity one
query
from this so um
but that's not easy to test i mean this
also is like
easily computable
so we can do the following
this function is have has global
sensitivity one
so you take gi subtract ti from it
divide by the delta so this will give
you like
change of sensitivities plus one is
necessary just to make the threshold
proper and zero
so if it goes below zero so this guy can
go only below zero when this quantity is
negative
but that time it is 0 the function is
bounded from 0
and this is for all of them since i'm
taking the max so this is a global
sensitivity one query
given this proxy condition it becomes
like now it becomes
trivial to fit in the framework
will essentially compute d hat based on
this restriction strong convexity and my
strong stability
compute this tilde add laplace noise 1
by epsilon
if this tilde is greater than something
then support i then just return the
support of theta
and be happy with otherwise return abort
algorithm is differentially private
because i'm just using ptr framework
nothing special
the only thing non-trivial was done is
to compute this test
d hat now what does this bias over
sample and aggregate framework
it says that under consistency
assumptions and if you choose your
regularizer properly
with the dimensions log of the
dimensions sufficiently large
like alpha squared cube i'm not sure
this is necessary but for our proof it
comes up
shows up and you allow your number of
samples to grow as s log p
what alpha squared is is log 1 by delta
upon epsilon so if your log is like
higher than that your number of
dimensions
and your number of samples grows as s
log p now you see that there is no log 1
by delta 1 epsilon term
so i did this all this kind of geometry
stability and things like that
just to remove the log 1 by delta 1
epsilon now we remove it
but under this condition that when the
dimension is sufficiently large
then we with high probability we recover
the support of theta star
so i give you a differential private
algorithm for recovering the support of
the
true minimizer the underlying model
theta star
using lasso and this goes via studying
the stability property of the lasso
estimator
and this is like nearly optimal
essentially if i had
not had this condition then this would
have been the non-private
mount but i mean i have to have some
condition here
because i'm putting privacy so to lose
somewhere but it's not clear that i have
to lose this much so this is one of the
open problems that
can you get without this condition
anything like much weaker than this
condition
this brings us to the thesis of the talk
again
we wanted to show that if we have an
algorithm which is stable
in some sense of stability then we can
translate into differential private
algorithm
using some generic transformations and
the notions of stability we wanted to
look at
are perturbation stability and sub
sampling stability
so we had a sub planning stability based
algorithm
and we also had a perturbation stability
based algorithm the sub sampling
stability best was extremely simple
but it had like slightly weaker sample
complexity the perturbation stability
actually gave us much stronger
sample complexity and both these
algorithms which i showed for passing
integration
are computationally efficient
so what did i tell you i told you about
generic transformation of getting a
differentially private algorithm
just via using perturbation stability
then i told you about sample and
aggregate framework using the ptr
using the ptr as an aggregator and
use it for private model selection in
the third part i reviewed
some results in sparse linear regression
and the fourth part we designed
private's parts linear regression
using the stability properties stability
stability preserving algorithms which we
designed in the first two parts
so this is the thing which i told you
now to make some concluding remarks
the sample and aggregate framework with
ptr plus potential max is a pretty
generic tool actually
for designing different learning
algorithms so one example is
suppose i have so the learning problem
is non-convex let's say
so the tools which you know for provable
guarantees for like outputting the model
in a non for the convex problems does
not anymore hold because the stability
of the model is not
sure because it can just jump around the
minima
so in such a case it is not clear how to
make it differentially private
but what if i don't output the model i
just make sure that the predictions
which i give
are differentially private
maybe you can do something there and the
sub sampling
and aggregate framework kind of becomes
useful there
good comments and this is ongoing work
with
misha velenko synthetic work and guide
author
the ptr framework is a pretty
interesting and simple tool
as long as you don't know how to design
this distance to instability frame
distance to instability property
third is like a pretty open problem is
that
to be fair the conditions under which
the consistency conditions for the
support recovery of lasso
which i feel is like extremely strong in
real life this might not actually hold
and in in the other way the sense we
know that
without those conditions even without
privacy you cannot get recover the
support of lasso
but the question is like why do i
sometimes in most of the times why do i
care about the support
i might want a sparse model which has
good generalization ability
as my underlying model and in the
non-private world we know that such
algorithms exist
but in the private world we don't know
so the question is
can we get private high-dimensional
learning without assumptions like
incurrence and restricted strong
convexity
so on that note i want to stop
can you actually go back and explain to
me again why you need this where this
upper bound on s came from in the
last slide on um this game
yes yeah explain to me why
kind of the same question suppose i keep
throwing into your
matrix a bunch of other irrelevant
columns just random
that will artificially increase speed no
but
that might violate your influence the
consistency conditions
okay so yeah so
that the for to tell about this i have
to go to this picture this three
three dot picture where is the three dot
pictures
no it's like much ahead
yeah yeah
so i told you that consistency
conditions imply the proxy condition
right
now to scale up the proxy consistency
conditions slightly
and the way i scale it up to make sure
that i am not like
paying on the sample complexity my log p
has to grow slightly higher than that
because
when i am telling about this kind of
closeness in the l2 or l infinity metric
under restriction strong convexity of
the minimizers
so i pay something conditions there's no
such dependents
no so consistency conditions are bunch
of constants but it's not nothing like
i mean in your case s has to be very
very small compared to
even compared to yes p so where does
that come from i don't see how this
comes
out of the consistency no this doesn't
cover the consistency condition the
consistency condition to imply this
proxy conditions
you need that so basically what i want
to say is that
i just do not lose anything in the
asymptotics
while trying to imply that so yeah there
seems to be an explanation
one issue is that so basically you know
the actual sample complexity is a
maximum or a sum of a few different
terms right
and uh you know so some of those
are have one over epsilons in them
and one of them doesn't and for in order
for the one that doesn't
dominate you know basically so if you
want if you
if your question is when does the
non-private sample complexity dominate
the sample complexity of the private
version the answer is well when those
other terms are small
are small relative to s-log so this is
the regime in which you don't this is
the regime in which you you basically
don't this is not a requirement for the
algorithm to work no no no
it's it's just that uh you know in some
sense yeah in order for the
those one over epsilon terms not to be a
big deal
you need yeah so it's uh
so the dominant term is not multiplied
by right
yes that's what you see the dominant
term is the
non-private sample complexity in that
routine right
right and and so um the the difference
with the sub sampling based algorithm is
you always pay
for you always pay a factor of 100 which
you know if you're running lots of
algorithms and you have a small private
sleep budget that could be advocated
your substance that likes it was only
for the this normal design matrix
yeah the way we analyzed was only for
the normal design and
just for deterministic conditions i
don't think the sub sampling
stability always holds if i just assume
the consistency conditions
this is kind of potentially weaker than
that
yes normally you can also use probably
but yeah but i need some sort of
stability
there so to get perturbation stability
there the easiest we thought was to look
at deterministic conditions and
kind of because while designing
differentially private algorithms we
cannot assume any
kind of distributions so deterministic
conditions are easiest to work with
so it's a converse somehow probably
obvious that
if it's if there's no stability then you
cannot get differential priority is that
i mean it must be some theorem of that
nature yeah because
in some sense it is true because if i
just change one sample
the fact that one sample is affecting my
output so much
you can get practically just like
utility
questions we have exactly of time
okay then
you